Mexico is experiencing a sharp rise in
violence
some of the most notable examples in
recent weeks include a series of
roadside bombs in the state of Jalisco
that left four police officers dead
and an attack against security forces in
the state of Chiapas that led to the
kidnapping of 16 police employees
experts say that while these incidents
may be attributed to Turf Wars between
rival gangs the overall increase in
violence could be linked to the gearing
up of election season
it would have to be examined on a
case-by-case basis but effectively when
faced with changing political
candidacies different groups began
moving their chips be they political or
through the use of violence This Is How
They gain their space against their
Rivals to show how much influence they
wield security analysts say the
influence criminal groups have over
politics is most evident during campaign
seasons
and nowhere in the country is this more
apparent than in Mexico's hotlands
namely the state of Guerrero earlier
this month a large demonstration
organized by a drug gang near the resort
city of Acapulco led to the Abduction of
several government officials even
Mexico's president made reference to the
clout criminal groups in the state have
over citizens
don't be fooled it is a common practice
by some criminal groups to create a
social base of support
some estimates suggest there are as many
as 200 armed criminal groups vying for
power in Mexico experts say many of
these groups are able to thrive because
of their ability to make deals with
government officials who in turn afford
them impunity and even positions of
power
organized crime by its nature needs a
state to be able to circulate all of its
illegal merchandise to operate in
financial systems as complex as those in
countries like Mexico Colombia and
Brazil
despite national elections still a year
away many argue that criminal
organizations here have already started
taking advantage of early campaigns with
the aim of leveraging state power for
illicit purposes as political campaign
season in Mexico draws near there's
concern that violence which is already
at record highs could become worse as
the country struggles with the seemingly
impossible task of severing the bonds
between criminals and authorities Manuel
rapalo Al Jazeera Mexico City